Chason who do you think should get into
acting and who do you think maybe acting
might not be for huh
well uh I think acting is for people who
want to learn more about how people work
and who want to tell stories and who
don't mind making themselves look
ridiculous oh man that's exacting can be
so many things and there's so many
stories that we can tell I mean I think
I think acting is just a way to figure
out what motivates people and it's a way
to understand why we tell the stories
that we tell because we've been spelling
stories for thousands of years and you
know we think about how many movies come
out of a year and how many TV shows come
out of a year and and and how many well
I wish there were more plays that came
out every year but so the fact that we
still watched so many movies and devote
so much time the television and and
books and all these things and says that
stories are obviously important you know
I think people do like to treat them as
just disposable and escape I think the
type of escape that you go to says a lot
about what you want and the characters
UI that people identify with says a lot
so I think if you want to figure out
what makes people tick but also learn
more about yourself by discovering what
you relate to with a character what you
don't really do with the character and
what you can portray then I think acting
is for you I think if you if you're
willing to injure hundreds of auditions
without getting anything and devote a
lot of time to examining yourself and
your habits and your essence and seeing
like how it is you portray yourself then
yeah I think it's for you if you like to
set you feel like playing pretend it's
for you if it's not for you let me
obviously we need people make the world
run we need to diggers and we need
firemen and we need furniture builders
and we need plumbers and we need trying
to make stuff happen like that in a very
in a very visible way like here's this
table and I make this table then acting
is not for you if you
I don't know it's it's hard to really
say I mean if you don't want to be
exposed like that then acting is not for
you if you don't want to dress up in a
silly costume then acting's not for you
how did you know it was for you was
there
was there a moment I mean you know
before your role on the secret life of
an American teenager did you see
something else or experience another
movie set something where you thought I
think this is something that I'm willing
to go through the good times in the bad
whatever happens with it well I went to
an acting camp called the Columbia Gorge
School of theater for seventh straight
summers from when I was eleven till I
was 17 oh and it was a place where a lot
of people from various ages from
Toddlers to teenagers came and we had a
couple movement teachers and a dance
teacher and a music teacher every year
and Jesse was the acting teacher in the
head of the camp and it was up in
Washington State just in the middle of
nowhere in the mountains and a lot of
weird kooky crazy people were there with
different perspectives and it was a
place where you could be whoever you
wanted to be which I liked in which I
liked about acting too I think you can
be whoever you want to be whether you're
Christopher Walken or or Chris Hemsworth
you can be whoever you want to be and
there's a place for everybody in acting
and I figured that out at CGS T cuz
Jesse wanted to make sure there was a
place for everyone at CGS t as long as
you respected each other and he got
along so that really made me want to act
and I think I just figured out again
like I said I figured out how people
worked through acting and in terms of
what like what moods I'm curious what
does that mean what mood moved people
what motivated people our secrets our
desires what we fantasize about and the
actions that we choose to take I
remember I saw the aviator with Leonardo
DiCaprio was Howard Hughes
and I I was I think 13 almost no I was
12 almost 13 when I saw that film which
is a very they're adult film but I just
remembered being intrigued by this man
who had all these these visions of what
he wanted and he was willing to do
anything to do and he challenged people
and he was so charismatic but he also
was quite quite affected in his mind you
know he had obsessive-compulsive and
could be quite neurotic and I remember
being so I just I was if I member that
was the first time I ever really really
wondered how an actor did that and I
thought what did he have to do to betray
all these tics and all these different
stages of this character and all these
different sides to him and then how did
he do that on camera
and what would he have to do to prepare
for that and then I was just kind of
fascinated by this outsider man and I
was kind of fascinated by how cuz you
know Caprio he doesn't really look a lot
like the real Howard Hughes Howard
Hughes was quite a tall imposing man he
had quite a rugged heavy face when he
was young and Howard Hughes is not that
Caprio is quite he's more youthful and
he's kind of more slender and and he's
got more of a youthful face but I
thought he I believe the ambition that
he had and the kind of the fragility
underneath the bravado particularly the
seem he's a Katharine Hepburn's house
you know Cate Blanchett's Hepburn and
all this old money he's just a boy from
Texas who got money and I think they say
something like we don't care about money
here and he says and he just kind of
he's looking down I can't even look him
in the eye
he's his billionaire he says well you
know that's because for you money has
never been an object and I just remember
like just kind of yeah being like that
struck something in me when he just kind
of was not a place at the dinner table
you